hallo leute wir begrüßen euch wieder zu
einer neuen apple würde von esi german
während heute im bundespresseamt in
berlin und wirbelt sie eingeladen worden
von der schwarzkopf stiftung junges
europa also wir alle sind eingeladen
worden
als konferenzteilnehmer und wir machen
hier tatsächlich einen medienworkshop
und für fragen politiker experten aber
auch junge leute was europa ihnen
bedeutet und an welchem europa sie leben
möchten und wir hatten die chance in den
letzten zwei tagen hier mit drei
kamerateams unterwegs zu sein
das sind unsere interviewer und unsere
interview gruppe und wir zeigen euch
jetzt mal die resultate
[Musik]
in europa wollen wir gerne leben ich
möchte gerne in einem europa leben das
so wie heute ein offenes europa indem
ich von einem land ins andere reisen
kann offen aber auch sicher indem wir im
freien austausch von menschen gedanken
und auch waren haben ja es sind alle
drei elemente zusammen für dieses europa
haben wir lange gearbeitet in meinem
mann nach ist in europa das bis zu
verteidigen lohn
aber ich glaube ich dass kopf zu sagen
aber ich würde gerne in den vereinigten
staaten von europa leben also ich würde
mich freuen wenn der euro fällt
natürlich noch viel weiter gehen würde
und zukünftig diesen nationalen grenzen
zwischen den europäischen staaten noch
deutlich an bedeutung verlieren würden
ich würde gerne im vereinigten europa
leben in einem europa das zusammensein
schicksal in die hand nimmt und habe ein
bisschen angst
lassen sie uns jetzt auseinander fällt
und dass meine kinder wieder da anfangen
wo meine eltern angefangen haben erdmann
europa muss sehr leckere schokolade gibt
das finde ich dabei nicht vergessen die
welt ist der aber scheint der einzige
planet wird schokolade gibt aber es herz
beiseite vielleicht ist es gar nicht so
herzhaft weil dadurch dass wir zum
beispiel offene grenzen haben kann ich
einfach nach belgien fahren und mir dort
belgische schokolade kaufen oder noch
besser die belgische schokolade kommt am
einfachen günstigen ich kann sie hier
kaufen und kann dann schauen wenn
schwäche ist denn eigentlich besser
jetzt die lokale schokolade oder halt
belgische schokolade und ich glaube
dieses europäische projekt für das
grenzen abbauen und gleichzeitig ich sag
mal das lokale erhalten und das überall
kennenzulernen
das ist etwas was ich unheimlich
bereichern finde
ich möchte weiter in einem europa neben
in dem ich mit keine grenzen gibt
in europa wo ich das gefühl habe dass
ich mitgestalten kann als europäerin
das heißt ich würde auch gerne mehr
haben als staatsbürger der europa mit zu
gestalten als glaube das parlament
sollten gestärkt werden die rolle des
parlamentes ich finde dass der rat
eigentlich zu viel macht hat und dann
dadurch das hat eben doch immer noch die
nationalen regierungen der viel
mitbestimmen
ich würde mir ein europa wünschen dass
ich mehr traut und dadurch auch den
bürgern mehr zutraut und dass sich die
bürger auch mehr trauen weil ich glaube
dass ich viele schon so als europäer
fühlen auf eine der jungen generation
dass man denen auch menschen frauen
mütter auch das europäische projekt wenn
wir uns überlegen das des eu-parlamentes
einzige parlamentes wo parlamentarier
aus verschiedenen staaten
zusammenarbeiten und verbindliche
beschlüsse fassen man dann auch noch mal
bedenkt dass vor
ich sag mal ein bisschen mehr als 70
jahren die vertreter aus diesen ländern
anstatt miteinander zu diskutieren
aufeinander geschossen haben finde ich
das von innehalten 70 jahren ist das ein
großer fortschritt und zeigt uns auch
wozu wir als menschen in der kooperation
als fähig sind und ich glaube zum
beispiel ganz stark an menschliche
kooperationen bei die uns ermöglicht
häuser zu bauen brücken zu bauen oder
halt nur europäische union in einem
europa das wetter zusammenhält ein
bisschen solidarischer ist also im
moment ist
in welchen europa möchten sie leben
technologische zusammenarbeit vertiefen
erwarten frühzeitig immer so dass sich
mit anderen jungen leute in europa etwas
zusammenarbeitet dann werde ich
eigentlich ganz viel habe ich auch das
gefühl dass wir viel mehr 1 1 glück zu
tun haben das gesetz deutschland der
kunst in europa möchte ich leben
ja also nein ambitionen wäre eine
föderale europa zu leben also ich warten
maschinen dem jungen europäischen
föderalisten und um viele wirklich
europa zu verändern also in diese
richtung für mehr für die religion in
europa will ich leben dass die leute
zusammen nehmen dass die leute
miteinander reden was wir heute machen
eigentlich in deutsch niederländische
gruppe das für mich so verspannt und da
dürfen wir auch auf die europäische
ebene dann erweitern endlich dass ihre
männer durch bin selbst franzose aber
mit deutschen und polnischen wurzeln und
das war auch mein ideal
die leute bewusst sind dass die europäer
sind 100 europa-tour gut ist auch in
zeiten der globalisierung findet euro
parallel richtig jetzt ich würde auf
jeden fall in einem vereinten europa
leben und vor allem die probleme wegen
überzeugt dass das machen müssen
ich mache mir große sorgen aufruf im
augenblick über die tendenzen der
abwanderungsgelüste und ich finde dass
leute hielt mir noch wieder für europa
ausgehen müssen dass das zu wenig
passiert
ich werde gerne bisher in welchen europa
messen am liebsten in einem europa in
der alle menschen vor allen dingen alle
junge menschen die gleichen chancen
haben in der freiheit und sicherheit
gewährleistet ist und in europa in dem
junge mensch noch immer wieder ihre
eigene zukunft sehen
das ist europa das ich mir vorstelle
sich kurze stellen reicht nicht
deshalb werde ich dafür streiten und
kämpfen in welchem europa möchten wie
leben ja also ich würde gerne in einem
rasen europa leben und wo sich die
menschen respektieren und im gemeinsamen
mit der europäischen union eben eine
gemeinsame organisationsform haben in
der insbesondere jetzt der
flüchtlingskrise gemeinsam lösungen
gefunden werden können
das trifft mich jetzt sehr unerwartet
ich würde gern in ein
vielfältigen europa lehner vom bag
gekennzeichnet ist wo alle nationen
überhaupt von nation sprechen wollen
gleichberechtigt nebeneinander und
miteinander leben ich möchte wirklich
ein europa aber dass menschen sich
gemeinsam mit prof
tief in der geschichte und wissen auch
dass wir nicht auch in einander leben
können wir haben ihn sein fett weg
gehabt haben gesagt er würde nie mehr
stopfen wollen wir sind dann wissen wir
versuchen mit wirtschaftliche frage mit
umweltfragen mit migrationsfragen wir
brauchen ein europa hat eine sehr innige
geschichte ja viele auseinandersetzung
aber auch viele themen die uns wieder
zusammengebracht haben
sie haben im laufe der jahrzehnte
gemerkt dass es nicht mit ein ohne
einander geht und dafür nur miteinander
wirklich erfolgreich sein können und
mehr als je zuvor als jetzt auch in
zusammenhalt der europäischen union und
sehr wichtig und ich glaube dass europa
in dem ich leben möchte eine oper was
gemeinsame wert erkennt und diese auch
hochhält und damit auch eine
wertegemeinschaft weg von der aktualität
nationalität denke ich ist ein wichtiges
thema was überall auf der welt präsent
ist aber nämlich im zeitalter wo es viel
mehr vermischung von aktualitäten gibt
was über kultur was integration ich
glaube dass momentan die fragen die uns
am meisten beschäftigen und zu denen wir
eigentlich zu lösungen kommen können
wenn wir uns eher von der aktualität
entfernen und er auf gemeinsame werte
achten und dadurch auch in der
gemeinschaft schaffen die sich vor allem
dadurch definiert und nicht durch
könnten ja jetzt seid ihr eingeladen mit
uns zu diskutieren wenn ihr aus europa
seit oder auch wenn ihr mit aus europa
seit schreibt und über die entwicklung
in europa in welchem europa möchtet ihr
gerne leben oder was denkt ihr in welche
richtung sich die europäische union
entwickeln wir hoffen dass wir viele
politische viele interessante vokabel
mitgenommen habe aus dieser es würde und
danken euch zu sehen und seien bis zum
nächsten mal